ちゃららら～ん（効果音）
男子）ｸﾞｯﾌw おいしいねぇw
女子）ｳﾍｪ”w そうねえw
男）ﾁｯ
男）あいつらうぜぇな
男）ちょっくら ぶつかってやっか！
男）通りすがりのリュクサックラリアット!!
男）はぁっ!!
ﾃﾞｭｸｼ!
女子）ｲﾀｧ"⤴
女子）痛いわね！(2つの意味で)
倍返しよ!! (懐)
ﾃﾞｭｺﾞｫｩ
そして男は 病院送りになったのであった...
ちゃああらりろぉん（効果音）
男A）おいおいおい お前ハロウィンどうだった？
男A）ハﾛｳｨﾝ... お前、なにした？
男B）ぁあぁ、オﾚ↑?
男B）おれｧ...
男B）俺は友達とハロウィンパーティーしたよ？ （ﾄﾞﾔ
男B）女もいるぜ？（煽り
男B）で、俺は かぼちゃのコスプレしたんだ
男B）いいだろ？
男A）いいなぁ  俺なんて
男A）家で一人で
男A）赤いギャラドスのコスプレしてたぜ
（どっちかっていうとコイキングじゃね...？）
男B）それから...
男B）彼と口をきくことはなくなった...
ちゃらららららん（効果音）
ﾜｱ"ｧｧ すごい！ ﾛﾎﾞ↑ﾀﾝだﾛﾎﾞ↑ﾀﾝ！
ｳ"ﾜ"ｱ"ｧ
ロボタンだｱ"ｧ"
わ"すごい近くで見れたｽｺﾞｲﾅｰ
ロボタンい" ぃな"ー
ゼロ距離で見るとサイコー！
ア”↑ァ”！
視力が！
なぐな”っちゃったぁ"ー
ちゅろろろろろん（効果音）
HI◯AKIN）ﾌﾞﾝﾌﾞﾝﾊﾛｰﾕｰﾁｭｰﾌﾞ
ﾌﾟﾙrrrrrrrrr
ｸﾞｼｭｺｫ"-
新しい封筒ー
裏声）yahhhhhhhhh
うぁぁすごい！神だｧ...
ﾊｯ↑ﾊｯ↑ﾊｯ↑ﾊｯ↑ﾊｯ (発作
ｳｩｩｯ これこそ 私の求めていた存在...
何この人！　感動だわ！
面白すぎて
ゲンコツで殴っちゃいそう
ちゅろろろん（効果音）
青）おい! この車貸せよぉ
緑）あっ ﾝやめてよぉ
青）うるせぇよ
早着替えして赤）おらっ 貸せつってんだろ！
早着替えして青緑）痛いよやめてよ！
着替えなおして緑）やめろって言ってんだろ！
着替えなおして青）うるせぇうるせぇ おrrらぁおrrらぁ
着替:ry 赤）だぁ"っ
ﾊﾟｺﾞｫｩ
全治9か月
ちゅろろろん（効果音）
お馬さん ぱっかぱっか お馬さん ぱっかぱっか
女の子)shhhｨｨﾈｪ"ｪ"ｪ
ちゅろろろん（効果音）
ママ）たけしぃ♡ はぁい お小遣いよぉ(裏声
たけし）あ ありがとうママｧ"
たけし）パパみてぇ  ママからもらったお小遣いで株やったら
たけし）すごぃ...  3000万円くらい儲かったよ(適当
パパ）ほぉーすごいなぁ
それからたけしは 全てを捨て不登校になり
部屋から出ず ずっと株を続けた
株で稼いだお金で2台目のスマートフォンを買い
寝る間も惜しんで
視力とかもう..どうでもいいから  ｶｯ株やりまくった
移動中も時間が惜しいたけしは
歩きスマホをするようになり
案の定
車に引かれ 大怪我。
全治　12ヶ月
ちゃああらりろぉん（効果音）
ｱｰ↑ すごｫいロボタンだｧ"
ﾜ"ｧ"ー ロボタンだ
すごいなｧ⤴
はぁぁすごいｯ///はぁｧ
近くで見ると 金属の光沢がすごいぃ！
スキダ―(棒
あれっ
あっあぁやべ
僕ロボタンになっちゃった
食べられちゃったよ☆
ちゅろろろろろん（効果音）
ﾌﾟﾙrrrﾝ
ﾁｭﾝﾁｭﾝﾁｭﾝﾁｭﾝ
ﾁｬﾘﾝﾁｬﾘﾝﾁｬﾘｰﾝ
ｼﾞｭﾙﾙｯ
俺の名前はとしろう。
パチンコにハマって
約..5年
ついにお金を底が尽きてしまった(?)
もう俺の手元にお金はねぇ(ｷﾘｯ
友達からも金をせが..み 借りまくり
そして  元カノからもお金を借りまくり (この顔である
せがんで...ついには親からもらっている
大学の仕送りを使ってﾊﾟﾁﾝｺするようになってもーた
それもすぐお金が無くなって 俺はついに
お金が無くなってしまった（2回目
寝る前もついつい金のことを考えちゃう
そこで俺はひらめついた(新語
犯罪をすりゃあええんや Σ旦(ﾟДﾟ)
俺はあらゆる犯罪をやった
銀行の..金庫から..ぉ金を 取って...
闇金からお金を借り(エコー
おやじ...
お金持ってそうなおやじを狩り(ショボい
つかまってもーた
ぷんぴろぱりぽれぽれ～（効果音）
ﾌｳｩｰｰーーーーﾝ
ズブｳ"ｳ"ｳ"ｳ"ｩｩ"ｩｫ"ｫ"ｫ"ｫ"ｫ"ｫ"ｫ"ｫ"ｫ"ｫ"ｫ"ｫ"ｫ"ｫ"ｫ"
皆さん早く！避難してください！
隕石が落ちてきています！   ※落ちた
早く！
？）おーいたけしー
ドン!!!
たけし）うわあ”ぁぁ (突然のピンチ
たけし）はっ！
優男）大丈夫かい君ｨ！
たけし）ﾀｽｹﾃｪ"ｪ"
たけし・優男）あ”あ”あ”ぁ”ぁ”
ﾌﾟｩｩｩｩｩｫｫｫｫｫｫｫｫｫｫｫｫｫｫｫﾝ (なぜか優男が落ちる
ﾎﾞｸﾞｼﾞｭｯ
DEAD.